sing by Andrew thank you my gut and
thank you for coming let's see okay
great so this talk is about the search
for improved algorithms for NP complete
problems like set a set of a satisfiable
boolean formulas so you can keep that as
a sort of big-picture goal in mind we
believe perhaps p is different from NP
but we can still hope to look for
improved algorithms all right there's no
there's no reason why complete rout
first brute force has to be the truth
indeed when you look at the literature
the true time complexity as far as we
know of NP complete problems seems to
have fairly diverse behavior so for some
you know like circuit satisfiability
we're stuck we can't even beat brute
force by any super polynomial factor for
others we have some kind of exponential
speed-up and it also seems that
different algorithmic techniques work
well for different problems so what can
what can we say about this this
situation what can complexity theory
contribute well a basic observation not
new is that most of the algorithms we
have four important problems fit into a
reasonably small number of basic
frameworks or paradigms such as dynamic
programming algorithms branching linear
programming SDS TP based algorithms and
so on so an ongoing project of myself
and other researchers is to try to
identify and formally model some
reasonably broad and powerful paradigms
for solving NP complete problems and try
to prove limits on these paradigms for
at least some NP complete problems that
help in a way that helps us explain why
some problems seem easier than others
and why some techniques are amenable in
certain cases and in particular you know
if you're familiar with things like the
exponential time hypothesis we'd like to
for for particular paradigms like these
we'd like to give evidence that
exponential time say is required for
some problems based on evidence or based
on assumptions that are that are weaker
or more modest than the eth
okay and we know that you know they've
been powerful results on limits of some
of these already so today's paradigm
that I'm going to be talking about is
one known as Colonel ization but it's
also can be can be thought of as
referred to as pre-processing okay so a
formal model of this is due to down Ian
fellows and their work on fixed
parameter complexity and the motto of
this approach is to give it an input to
a hard problem first try to efficiently
shrink that instance okay try to shrink
it as much as we can and then solve the
the shrunken instance okay here's the
framework we have some decision problem
L think of it as sat or some other NP
complete problem we want to know whether
some instances in El Sol a kernel
ization reduction is a polynomial time
reduction which takes X and maps it to
some hopefully smaller X Prime and we
require that these two are equivalent as
far as membership in L is concerned the
next step in this paradigm is to just
solve this reduced instance by some
solver which we can think of as just a
an exponential time or brute force
solver we're not as concerned with this
part here but once we solve X X prime we
know the answer to X
so our focus is going to be squarely on
the first part of this picture and in
trying to understand what kind of
achievable compression amount there is
for various problems
so I guess the high-level motivation for
this theory is that pre-processing and
this kind of pruning or simplifying of
hard instances before applying brute
force is a common and useful thing to do
we'd like to give a theoretical account
of how much we can achieve just by this
this first step of efficiently
pre-processing
but a cautionary note if l is
np-complete then in the worst case we
can't even expect to reliably shrink our
instance even by a single bit and the
reason is if we can do that we can do it
again and again and again and in
polynomial time solve a baby-sized
instance ok which which gives us the
answer for the original so we have to
lower our sites and what downing fellows
suggest is to focus on instances where
some input parameters some measure of
the complexity of difficulty of the
instance is assumed small so this leads
to this formal model of parameterised
problems where each instance comes with
a parameter K a number giving some
notion of its difficulty and and now we
can hope for compression guarantees
which take into account not just the
input size but also the input parameter
in particular one ambitious guarantee is
to hope that the output size the size of
X Prime be bounded by some polynomial in
K the parameter independent of the input
size so could be much smaller than the
next itself
this might seem abstract but we'll get
to a concrete example soon and such a
reduction such a kernel ization is
referred to as a polynomial kernel for
the input parameter K alright so with
respect to this measure of complexity of
the problem so it's polynomial in two
senses once one this reduction r is
polynomial time but this polynomial
means that the output size has this
polynomial guarantee
so this again seems ambitious but
actually there are many success stories
to this approach to algorithm design a
polynomial kernel is is useful for for
outright solving the problem because a
polynomial kernel for an NP problem
automatically yields an algorithm with
the following runtime ok we have a
polynomial factor independent of K for
the the pre-processing step then we have
some exponential and K term here for the
second solving step all right and this
runtime is what is known as fpt or fixed
parameter tractable it's favorable for
small values of K and the reduction
should run in time polynomial in and the
input length yeah and this gives either
the best known or at least competitive
fpt algorithms for many NP complete
problems so let me show you the market
Bend on Vicki okay I'm just wondering
why it's mark times and it's a plus it
can zip it can be a poly n times f of x
f FK but it's it's more or less
equivalent yeah so vertex cover is the
classical example Sam bust and the 80s
gave a polynomial kernel for this
problem recall that in the vertex cover
problem we have a graph and we're given
a budget k and we want to know whether G
has a vertex cover of size K that is a
set of at most K vertices that
collectively are adjacent to every one
of the edges in this graph so is this a
vertex cover not quite we missed this
edge but if we throw in this green edge
the screen vertex we have a vertex cover
okay this is an np-complete problem so
we can't hope to solve it outright but
let's just think about the case where we
have a reasonably small budget you know
where K is small and we're hoping to
simplify our instance on that basis okay
so suppose K is 3 for this example and
let me highlight this this note here
which has high degree can this can we
forward to not include this vertex in
our cover no we can't because there are
too many edges out going to it if we
didn't include this for texts we have to
include all of its neighbors and that's
too many so so we can simplify this
instance we know that this has to be
included let's just include it so to
pluck it out of the graph simplify and
we reduce our budget by one okay so
generally any vertex has degree more
than K must lie in our cover so we can
repeatedly add all of these vertices to
our cover until there are no more of
them or we might run out of budget okay
in which case we know there's no
solution so ties there's no tie here we
can you can just pluck any vertex of
degree more than K so suppose we survive
this process we pluck away all the high
degree vertices the resulting graph G
prime is a degree at most K now how many
edges are left in this graph there could
still be a lot of edges but if there's
too many I claim that we can't possibly
cover them all because each remaining
vertex only covers so many all right
there more than K squared we're stuck
otherwise we've reduced our original
graph to an equivalent vertex cover
instance where the number of edges is it
on the order of K squared and so the
number of vertices is also in the order
of K squared when you pluck out there
irrelevant ones ok so this is a
polynomial kernel for this problem the
order of K squared can be reduced to
order of k and yeah there are many more
nice algorithms like this ok so here
again is the formal set up for these
polynomial kernels and now i want to
start talking about the theory of limits
to polynomial kernel ization
okay it's the focus of my work so for a
long time there's been some evidence
that many NP complete problems don't
have polynomial kernels for example the
cake leak problem where I want to find a
clique of size K this is believed not to
even have an FPT runtime algorithm okay
we believe that you require something
like n to the K or into the Omega K time
to solve it so we believe there's no FPT
algorithm and in particular noah
polynomial kernel ization but there's
been a number of algorithms are a number
of problems which do have FB t
algorithms but which seemed strongly
resistant to this polynomial kernel
ization approach to solving them and we
want to try to understand that
phenomenon so it turns out that by some
work beginning in the mid-2000s that you
can rule out Paul email kernels for many
more problems under standard assumptions
from complexity theory
so the starting point for this theory is
a two special we could call toy problems
okay there parameterised problems which
you wouldn't really consider for their
own sake but they turn out to be useful
for this theory if you just buy both
lender Danny fells and Hermelin and one
of them was studied with cryptographic
motivations by her neck and now or
earlier the first is the so-called or
set problem you're given a collection f1
through ft of boolean formulas each of
this particular length K which you can
think of as reasonably small compared to
T and our goal is to decide whether at
least one of these FIS is satisfiable
okay it's asking about the or of their
satisfiability there's also the ants at
problem which is the same or but now we
want to know whether each one of them is
satisfiable individually
so the criminalization task for this and
set problem would be to do the following
to produce a formula fee which is
satisfiable if and only if each one of
the input formula is satisfiable now
general internalization you're allowed
to output you know an instance of the
the starting problem so I could have put
a list here but any list can sort of be
reduced to a single formula by itself
reducibility of SAT so just think of the
output of our reduction as being a
single formula so we want a reduction
like this in the kernel ization problem
and to ask for a polynomial kernel would
be to demand that fee be of size at most
polynomial and K irrespective of T the
number of instances okay which would be
a powerful thing to do so for example
one thing that you could try to do is
sort of select the the out of a long
list of formulas the ones that you think
are the the least likely to be
satisfiable okay and then sort of
compile them into a formula we don't
know of any way to to solve this problem
to produce such a such a fee
when the bull endure at all conjectured
that no polynomial kernels exist for
these two problems that you can't hope
to do this
now why would they make this conjecture
well first what's the significance of or
set well via a collection of reductions
which can be seen to begin in hard
economic untrue hbu shins we've seen
that if this or set problem doesn't have
polynomial kernels then many other
problems don't either this is by often
straightforward reductions although some
are some are complex and one notable
example just to give you one is the K
path problem I give you a graph and a
number K and I want a simple non self
intersecting paths of length K ok you'd
like to somehow condense this problem to
a 2-1 on a small graph with something on
the order of poly k vertices we don't
know how to do this and in view of this
conjecture maybe it's not possible so
just to get the parameters do so yeah
each in the or sack problem each side
instances sorry besides it k yeah the
number is T and then T can be
arbitrarily large compared to decay
although you can yeah you can think of
it as something growing slightly super
polynomial with with K for example but
yeah the the reduction should be should
be polynomial time in the size of the
input list and then you want to shrink
it to a single set problem he sighs his
poly k
although we would be happy for even more
modest compression amounts than I'll
talk about that little too for the ants
at problem these authors showed that if
an SAT doesn't have polynomial kernels
then a different list of problems
doesn't have pollen email kernels as a
result so it has a different kind of
explanatory power and it doesn't seem to
be as wide in its explanatory power as
the or sat problem but still some nice
problems and maybe the most notable
example is the the tree with problem of
determining that the tree width of a
graph which is a very important quantity
for for dynamic programming programming
based algorithms to solve graph problems
so these problems all have fpt
algorithms as I mentioned and so what
the Orang and conjectures would imply is
that Colonel ization can't even match
the best-known run times for these
problems let alone beat them so this
points to an inherent weakness on on
this paradigm for specific classes of NP
complete problems it helps us understand
the diversity of NP of NP complete
problems themselves with respect to
their solvability by various paradigms
ok so why should we believe these or and
and conjectures you know do we just need
to accept them as new conjectures well
actually we have some evidence based on
a standard complexity theoretical
assumption that NP is not contained in
co and p poly if you believe that the
polynomial hierarchy is infinite for
example you've got to believe this as
well
and and this importantly speaking this
assumption can be glossed over as saying
that there are no short proofs of
unsatisfied bility of boolean formulas
even if you allow some non-uniform
advice or non-uniform information in
defining your proof systems so under
this assumption shortly after both under
a doll's work for now in San tanem
showed that indeed there are no
polynomial kernels for the or stat
problem and the inset problem was a bit
trickier but in in 2012 I showed that
under the same assumption nopal minimal
kernels for this problem either and
indeed I am able to extend both of these
results to randomize Colonel ization
where there's some small probability of
error in the reduction the both results
are are somewhat stronger quantitatively
than what's stated here but these are
just succinct statements and let me also
just mention that I proved a similar
negative result for a notion of quantum
compression it's sort of a some kind of
a quantum analogue of Colonel ization
that I defined in the paper but I'm not
going to discuss that any further
okay so let's talk about the proof ideas
for my work how much time do I have
so what we do is let yes um good so the
an set is a collection of distinct SAT
instances which you can think of being
as being on distinct they're disjoint
variable sets so it's not okay CSP is
like a bunch of constraints on a
commonly a common set of variables we
think of a case enf each one each one of
these CN f's or each one of these
clauses is individually satisfiable and
now so that so if you look at the end of
individual clauses each one is
satisfiable and so it's easy to solve
such a thing in our notion okay okay so
our approach is to assume that we have a
polynomial kernel for an SAT by
contrapositive and then use it to show
that NP is in Koenji poly and by work of
x by [ __ ] Goldwasser and sip sir on
interactive proof systems it's enough to
give so-called Arthur Merlin proofs for
the unsatisfied ability of boolean
formulas so it's enough to show how a
computationally powerful Merlin can
convince a computationally bounded and
skeptical Arthur that a given formula is
unsatisfiable ok so we have a polynomial
kernel for the ants at problem it looks
like this take some number of formulas
outputs of formula what are its
properties first of all we're going to
restrict attention to the case where all
of these f eyes are of some length K and
let's assume that that T is a large
polynomial in K the number that we're
going to feed to this reduction is a
large polynomial and K and remember that
we have a compression bound we have an
output size bound on this formula fee
we choose this this T large enough so
that this output size down is on the
order of t log T okay when you have this
kind of bound that will be the regime in
which we can apply the techniques and
use this artifact to prove unsatisfied
bility of boolean formulas if you have a
polynomial kernel for an set you can
always choose t large enough such that
this holds indeed you can prove you can
even get t large enough so that fee is
of size much less than T but we can get
quantitatively stronger results in this
in this range ok now the correctness
properties firstly if all of these
formulas are satisfiable I'm going to
use that use greens is note satisfiable
formulas then the output is satisfiable
as well but if even one of them is
unsatisfiable or red then the output is
unset okay so so those are the two
properties that we have and now we want
to use this thing so the variable sets
so yeah so again these think of these as
individual SAT instances they can each
be on their own variable set either way
the way we define it is just that there
we just want to know whether they're all
individually satisfiable so it doesn't
matter really but yeah
so we have a boolean formula G of length
K single formula and Merlin claims that
G is on set so so what does Arthur do to
check this possibly bogus claim ok so
the first thing that Arthur is going to
do is ask her some privacy this will be
a private coin protocol so he retreats
to his Kings quarters now we're going to
use this this and this this reduction by
this polynomial kernel for the ants at
problem so we need to generate some
inputs to this thing so the first thing
that Arthur is going to do is generate
some potential inputs to the to our
compression reduction ok he's going to
generate f1 through ft according to some
probability distribution now which
probability distribution that's really
the heart of the matter but for now just
think of it as some distribution next
Arthur is going to flip a coin the coin
is heads he's going to directly stick
these formulas into our reduction
outputting a formula fee and note that
in this case these these formulas that
we generate are always going to be
satisfiable so in this case the output
formula will be satisfiable if the coin
lands tails however then Arthur's going
to going to use this formula G that
Merlin claims is unsatisfiable and he's
going to stick G into one of the
positions to the inputs to our reduction
namely he's going to choose a random
position between 1 and T and insert G
there ok
and again he'll plug these in and he'll
get a formula which if Merlin was
telling the truth this would be an
unsatisfiable formula finally in either
case he sends the formula to Merlin okay
and merlyn's job is to guess which way
the coin landed okay we're going to
accept Merlin's claim about G if and
only if Merlin can correctly guess the
coin value okay so in this case where G
is truly unsatisfiable is claimed then
indeed Merlin learns the coin flip value
just by looking at the stats status of
what he gets so we can confidently
answer however suppose that Merlin was
lying and G is satisfiable then in this
case what Merlin gets is always
satisfiable so he can't use that
decision rule to answer this quiz okay
so we at least have the potential to
confuse Merlin Merlin's you know a very
clever guy so he could use other
criteria to try to see which which case
we're in so we really have to work some
how to choose these f 13 ft/s in the
right way that will cause Merlin to be
confused okay so the main technical
limit then is that we can do this there
exists an efficiently sample
distribution over these formulas it's
not a product distribution it has the
following property
for any satisfiable gee that Merlin
might try to lie about the output
distribution of this reduction is not
too strongly affected by the insertion
of G at a random coordinate not too
strongly affected sorry about that more
precisely the two cases that Arthur
could use where where G is or is not
inserted into the into the reduction the
outputs are at statistical distance
noticeably less than 1 between those two
cases this confuses Merlin because no
matter how smart he is if these two
distributions you know they might be
being sent are somewhat overlap then
there's no way you can reliably
distinguish the two
questions about this i should say
efficiently sampleble with non-uniform
information that's the asterisk
and the proof start to start starts to
involve some information theory which is
why I volunteered this talk and exploits
the fact that the output size is not too
large okay
so the first step is to simplify our
lives a little bit remember we want this
distribution which disguises the
insertion of an arbitrary G an arbitrary
satisfiable G but let's just simplify
our lives and imagine that G is drawn
from some fixed known distribution d so
in this case how should we respond what
kind of inputs should we choose in this
case well I think it's natural to guess
that they should look as much like G as
possible so let's just sample these
things independently from D itself ok so
that's our response in this special case
and indeed this works for most positions
I fixing the input as G doesn't affect
the output distribution by too much ok
namely the pre and post output
distributions have noticeably close
statistical distance and the proof
really follows from some closely similar
facts in the literature as far back as
roses work on a PRT but also clock nayak
Cashman Zuckerman proved much the same
kind of result in a more powerful
quantum communication setting and I just
want to mention a couple things that are
slightly different although they don't
really involve any technical work or
more technical work the first is that we
need to really need to in this in our
argument want to handle an arbitrary
distribution here and assert this for an
arbitrary distribution and combine this
fact ok so we're not it's not enough to
just look at say the uniform
distribution and the second is that for
quantitatively strong results to handle
the case where the output sizes at large
is the large as t log t it helps us to
use not not only the the pin square
inequality which is a classic
information theoretic tool used in those
earlier works i mentioned but also a
somewhat lesser known result of vajda
which says that two distributions are
noticeably far apart as long as their
divergence are relative entropy is
logarithmically founded okay so there
are these two nice things which can be
used to handle two different ranges of
the output size bound
so so based on this this fact we succeed
in our task of disguising the insertion
of G assuming G is drawn from some known
distribution d but it can be an
arbitrary distribution yes but we're
assuming that G is itself is satisfiable
we're just looking at the case where
Merlin is lying and his claim done SAT
formulas really sad yeah so the next
step is to view this process is a
two-player game player one is tasked
with choosing G the satisfiable formula
and player 2 is being asked to choose
this distribution over f1 through ft and
player two's goal is to disguise the
insertion of G ok so that the output of
our is not affected too much in
statistical distance so informally let
me say that player 2 wins if the
distribution the output distribution of
our disguises the insertion of G and
then and so that the output distribution
of our is not too much different
according to whether or not G was
inserted
so the the previous claim that I made
can be rephrased as saying that for
every mixed strategy of player one for
every distribution of possible choices
of player 1 of this formula G there is
an appropriate response for player 2
namely tea independent copies drawn from
D so this recalls a powerful result of
game theory the minimax theorem which
says that because we we can beat any
mixed strategy on the first players /
choosing G they're actually exists a
single mixed strategy for the second
player that wins against any G so we're
powerfully boosting our result here so
there's a single distribution over these
things which the wins against all g
which is what we wanted in the first
place the only hitch is that this magic
distribution that we got in this way
won't be efficiently sample because the
minimax theorem is not really fully
constructive so we need further work to
to achieve that and several steps
involving sort of modifying the
strategies that player 2 was using using
some approximate minimax theorems and so
on but this is the basic idea so I'll
stop there in conclusion criminalization
is a paradigm that's powerful enough to
have many success stories many nice
algorithms to its name yet also
meaningfully restrictive enough that we
can prove stronger limits for this class
of algorithms and I think it's
interesting to continuing to continue to
try to prove strong limits on more
paradigms of NP problems and perhaps
using an information-theoretic ideas
along the way so thank